find that sweet spot between aggressive
and stupid and the problem is and you
know maybe this actually helps phillip
rivers this year because i just think
the expectations for him when you
consider he's getting 25 million this
year from the colts brady's getting 25
million this year from the bucks drew
brees getting 25 million this year from
the saints i think the expectations for
him are lower than the other two
and a lot of the reason why it's so low
is we saw more stupid than aggressive in
prime time games last year seven
interceptions in back-to-back prime time
games i can't get that out of my brain
and what it does is it puts a low bar a
lower bar for phillip rivers than it is
for the other two guys and and maybe
that actually sets him up well to
surprise some people this season shireen
i was just thinking boy this is a team
that's really flying under the radar
because we haven't talked about the
colts much we haven't written about the
colts much they're just kind of there
but they do have a chance to win that
division in the division that they're in
you know you look at the texans and and
you look at the jaguars and the titans
you know the titans went to the aoc
championship game but cantana hell
duplicate what he did last year can
derek henry stay healthy so
when you look at this colts team you do
think they have a chance to win that
division but i haven't thought a lot
about the colts uh to be perfectly
honest about it and the question does
become how much does philip rivers have
left how are those legs
he hasn't been hurt but he did not look
good last season and maybe it was just
his decision-making and maybe he will be
a better decision maker in indianapolis
than he was last season this season for
the chargers
yeah i don't think it's something that a
team can really engineer it just has to
happen but a team has to love it when
something like this naturally evolves
where
no one's paying attention to that team
because what it does is it allows head
coach frank wright to maybe use that as
motivation hey nobody's giving us any
respect nobody thinks we're going to be
great and also at the same time nobody's
getting a swelled head because they
don't hear everyone talking about colts
colts cold schools cults and the cults
are so good and watch out for the colts
and and i think that that combination is
just it's just another brick that gets
put in the foundation for what can be a
really good season and we probably
should be taking the colts more
seriously and we should be
not underestimating philip rivers
because i think phillip rivers even
though he doesn't seem prideful per se
i think he's got enough pride that if he
didn't think he could get it done he
wouldn't keep playing the mere fact that
he's on the colts tells us that he
firmly believes he can play well and
play better than we saw him play in
those those prime time games with seven
interceptions in back-to-back weeks and
uh we we better be ready for a colts
team to be a hell of a lot better than
it was last year and to be a real factor
in the afc sheree
yeah and that defense looks really good
and that's why i think they have a
chance you know t.y hilton is he going
to stay healthy that's a question there
but to me the biggest question mark is
philip rivers is he going to make good
decisions if it does he still have
something left in the tank i know he
feels like he has something left to
prove of course never been to a super
bowl and i know he wants to get there
and that defense is ready to go to a
super bowl is the offense ready to step
up to match that and we've always looked
at the colts when they've had a healthy
andrew luck as a team to contend with
and i don't have that feeling that we're
looking at the colts now that way it's
going to take philip rivers stepping up
to make that happen
it's just amazing i just looked down at
the calendar august 21 2020. philip
rivers is the starting quarterback of
the indianapolis colts if i had uttered
that sentence on august 21 2019
i would have been asked to provide
a sample for a drug test
um
it's just amazing how quickly
things change in the nfl and we are
still less than one year removed from
andrew luck deciding out of the blue
that he's going to call it a career so
uh philip rivers we'll see what he can
do we'll see what the colts can do it
should make for an interesting twist
especially since for now we're not
paying attention come the end of
september we may be paying a lot of
attention to the call
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports